You know, in CSGO, no matter how far behind you are, no matter how bad the round is looking,
nothing tilts the enemy team off the
face of the earth better than a good ninja defuse.
I’m Colin for theScore esports and whether you're sneaking behind enemy lines for a last second defuse,
Or going for that ballsy last ditch smoke ninja.
I feel like I can watch these plays all day.
So lets do just that and sneak into it, with the Top 10 Ninja Defuses in CS:GO.
Kicking off our list at number 10 is a cheeky play from Dupreeh, who hides on Nuke’s B-site
before sneaking into an enemy smoke for a play that left LDLC rethinking the meaning of life.
(Casting)
At Number 9 we have one of the first 1v5 ninja defuses in CS:GO.
After disposing of four CLG players, it seemed like an easy round win for NRG,
but Tarik had other ideas.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 8 is a play from Happy who just says, screw it, as he goes in for
a gutsy defuse in the smoke right next to ChrisJ, leading to an unlikely round win for EnVyUs.
(Casting)
Our Number 7 spot goes to K0nfig.
Up 12-4 against Fnatic in the Quarterfinals of Epicenter: Moscow, the Dane was looking
to add some salt to the wound as he sneaks behind enemy lines to pull off a clutch for  the ages.
(Casting)
At number 6 we’ve got Jaxi in the finals of Adria Masters Season 2.
Down 12-7 to Bajini Pulenii, Nexus were looking for anything to get them team back in the game.
Jaxi delivered exactly that, with this slick 1v5 ninja to start an overtime comeback win.
(Casting)
Our next ninja defuse comes from PENTA’’s Tabsen, who plays a game of cat and mouse,
before pouncing on the perfect opportunity for a sick 1v4 ninja defuse to win the round.
(Casting)
Coming in at Number 4 is a 200 IQ play from Devil.
Faced with a 1v3, he jukes out the members of FaZe clan with this unbelievable clutch
that saw him fake an AWP save, before coming back for a last second defuse
(Casting)
Sneaking in at number 3 is Kjaerbye at Dreamhack Malmo.
After losing 4 teammates, Kjaerbye was looking for the hero play, as he hid in construction
on Inferno’s B site to pull off an incredible 1v5 ninja that would tilt EnVyUs off the face of the Earth.
(Casting)
Taking the runner up spot is the Polish legend himself at IEM Katowice 2016.
In a round that seemed impossible to win for Virtus.pro, Snax turned it all around with
this ninja defuse in a 1v5 situation against FaZe Clan.
Capping off our list at number 1 is none other
than Krimz, who shows us, he is an actual
ninja as he evades 5 TSM players
for
a
ninja defuse
to remember.